one distinction that you make is the
difference between control and manage
massive I wonder if you can expand on
that yeah again I mean again I'd be
happy to criticized on the fact that
it's semantics but um I think semantics
are really important yeah I think so but
I think if someone says for example look
come on control your emotions the
implication is the word control means
you can if you want to whereas that's un
kind because you can't manage your
emotions is different manage means you
hope you can do it but management is a
skill control is an option oh nice and
that's why I see the difference so I
think when I hear people saying control
your emotions I think that's quite
abusive almost to the person because
you're asking them to do something they
can't do it's like saying jump out the
window and fly you wouldn't do that and
yet so control your emotions we can't
otherwise we would you know nobody wants
to lose it emotionally so but manage
means you've got an option here and it's
a
skill